When I look at it
from the outside of the window of the company
, Tsubasaminato
Foot 4 It is quite complicated and sometimes it looks like a building in the high-spec world.
The appearance of the complicated highway is also the same.
Well, the human arterial or nerve, after
all
, people with various talents gather and let me do it together.
This word power for ameb Hanfa encens a
sorex Yeah, I've always liked the body, and even in the game world, the images are
beautiful and the story is highly
dramatic.  I was very attracted to the fact that it was called "Penge".
Well, at that time, I didn't eat the video and the story.
It feels like I'm standing,
just a riding walk, a half-hearted series, and I've been doing it for 25 years.
I talked a little about how the final fans are growing up, but for the next 25 years, I
'm going to create fans for each work.
The world of Levine Rufan Tajin created by the ambassador and our creators is becoming more and
more integrated, and
when I was a college student, I had ff 7 e, and I thought that this was Koga a.
Study method I used to go to school, but I'm going
to make a game without playing cows.
It doesn't fit, but I'm doing something like being promoted by myself in the white of the living room.
For example, what kind of world view and picture plate do you want to make this time?
Yeah,
everyone gave me an appearance and I used it as a reference,
so I had an image for some reason, but there were other people who had the same idea as the high-speed light meeting.
After that, I think that Mengko, a fantasy of love, is a strength that something new can change
. I'm always thinking about
how to mix and use new things there
voodoo Always sex s 4 playing  Game Launcher is as
Fellows Blue & Nude Game
tareas Fan Fans Bronze Fifteen Nuve Games
+ Large Major Gaming 4 sa
4 hk future sters t 4 Rosewood Distin and Arepo
Story Turn Well in my life
Everything
I thought it would be nice if I could make use of it because I was influenced by it,
but if I thought that something I saw normally would be nice, I would
like to take a picture with my mobile phone and use it as a material.
I think it's a gopro color that you can enter with the same feeling as touching the TV. 4 nc 2 t Needs-free
game
floater
satc belage  I
think it was a drama of three works. Lightning Returns Well, from the first filer's
thirty,
Fabra Nova Crystalis The new crystal story, the national monkey god, is a temple.
If you live in a system, the first work will be through the third work, but it's not all,
but it
's the
story of the gods to some extent. It's like the gods.
Gdeh pa sonos Paint Ferrary
Audi  s A Pixar-Very this time Writer's Floor Tiner Departure I took a picture
and a happened in the previous two works
.
It
is divided because it is the kind of attitude that people live in when they reach the point of breaking the world.
What I want to express is the
perishing world.  People who are left behind-like how they are alive are
being chased by new lives without getting old. It's been
500 years since
then, and what the gliding hero will do today is foro b 9
Saving the hearts of the people who survived the
world, or saving the world itself
is not the theme of this time
. I think that children are rarer than business magazines, but the
people who live there make a way.  The theme is whether or not you can go,
and you want to not only see more by applying customer feedback, but also want to participate in the play
more actively.
I think that the meaning of experiencing the character is
a part that has evolved abundantly as a result of having reached through the walk.
It is a
game with a Yuna Day concept.
Haa Motor 4 miros Pepiimed Price Anal Define  buno
Boo Boo padi Have the
actual tooth community see the play on the world tour a while ago. It's a very
important os for the benefit when the up and down appearance shows good around that.
If anything, it's a child sub-character. From the point of view of the fans, it's an
exhibition of works
at a banquet.
It's rpg, but the day before yesterday,
the tees went
up, and each character was a close-up to tomorrow
. I think it's an event or a scenario, so
I think you can enjoy that area.  However, that is the character that appeared in the second work, but I
can't say much in Ihara Jen, but let's just go here from the perspective of seeing it blooming very high
.
I think it's a new character to see how it grows on the contrary. It
's a character that is very popular with fans, so I think that in the
end,
I'd like to introduce it to the cheaper ones by talking about making friends.  Masuki
This time, I have a supporter,
Hopuku, with him.
I'd like to have some expectations for relationships,
but I'm looking forward to it.
Yeah, a very cute character
carries a very big fate and is much firmer than it looks.
I'd like you to look forward to what happens. It's just a
porting, isn't it? It
was drawn that that character has a lot of parents
and children.
I personally love this uncle because I think it's a character that really feels like that. I want Satsu's
father to be my dad.
Completion Please see Point Question 1 Tsuneo
Paris Works, how much fee will be judged? After all, the world
is a breakthrough series in 3 laps. After all, the character is the official character
.  So that person or the same school or
Boo Boo enom
The time to reach the goal is fixed and that is what is called a four-person police officer, but I
am making it so that the goal is to achieve the goal 13  It's difficult to
decide what to do if you pull it. I'm
asking everyone. I've
escaped from the Boo Boo star. I can't aura to protect the world.
The characters in the game live like
this, right? Even in places you've visited so far, the atmosphere changes steadily, such as the
shop clerk or the walking person in the 24-hour wallet.
It's dangerous at night and it's daytime,
but there are some differences depending on the country where we are introducing this
time.  It's Yamamachi
, but
I'm bigger than I expected when I placed it, and it's big enough to be seen from anywhere in the city,
so if you start it, you can go to its roots, so I'd like you to look up
.  When you look around the world that you've made so far in the series, or
when you touch the lives of the people who live there  There were many situations where I couldn't really observe that kind of thing,
but I don't know when the cups were a little surprised, but
that npc had a very rich reaction to various things.  I'm showing that
the bad part is gone. The
child is looking at the world in time. Direct thinking. The
place where you can see Nanicolor. The staff is already a place where you can go.
I want to eat seamlessly because they are connected to each other. I
really think
that you can have a core, and that's why you're going into the people who live there, so I'm using it with people, but that's the
other reason for this year
voodoo 3  And 13 is, yes, I made a game
by putting emphasis on various strategies by moving multiple characters at the same
time, so I dropped it to the place where only that character is moved by one of them this time.
How about looking at it? It
's the very first beginning of this battle. It's quite intuitive, or if you're renting a character, it
's
a strong feeling this time.  Ne Battle is also an important part of Ushikuni, which has been evolving through three works all the time
.
It's
a version that can release a lot of stress, so I think it's going to be a pretty refreshing year because
it's a fierce battle, so
I think it's an action that can be lightened by strengthening the action element.
That's why it
spread, but in
fact there are things like climbing on the bridge and getting caught by that Docrates, and
there is an element of breaking it in the ator, so there is a chance to attack the enemy during the battle.  There are some
elements, but I'm the one who is stiff, but it's that customization. If
you change the way of fighting, it's a building, so
rastaman design 7 to do in Tiger Kasmize I like Kushon
Fighting e to do Kuriyaki
Choose your favorite weapons and shields, and finally de  Just dressed
up with a decoration I have prepared 8 of these 8 I found my own Lightning
There are, so I
think that people who are not good at choosing by themselves should choose this combination.This
time, not only costumes but also weapons and
shields are prepared. Butt For example, each type is not ashamed.  It's
about vertical, but it's an element that hasn't been seen in Final Fantasy Starteen Thirteen 2 until now
. It's a
completely new decoration this time.
Of course, users can use 8 costumes, weapons, and shields.
You can choose freely in various games where the ems chief is a
spoon splic toranoana
voodoo Direct os type I won't come tomorrow, but I
'm a person with a very late-night ability who can see the character as a human being.
The great thing about him is that it
's the power of the image.
That's really believable, and I can't believe it, but it's so accurate, but I often
exchange my texts.
If you expand it
to a higher level, it will be one pixel, but that one pixel means
that you can see the public companion up to a fraction of one pixel, for
example, if you output it, the life of the child.
For example, this part is 98 top plate%
. What do you want to shift to the left with a bitter smile?
That kind of child time comes. I can't believe that I can't do that.
I think that the Aso
costume is a very talented creator who has a lot of talent as a human being, such as one of the cow grass and how to add facial expressions
.
I mean,
I'm making a tape outfit that she hasn't really seen before. If you can see it at first glance, it
's like one person from the time of anxiety.
Player
I wonder if it was only a player to say that it was more like this due to the release of some works. It was
from Crystal c 4 that I was carrying the fateful things of the world, but the gods
and the fate of the world.  It ’s
very high because I ’m carrying my fate on my back.
Seo ’s thing is changing
.  Hey,
it's cool with a lot of style changes. It's really fun with lots of clothes.
Rim 4
uh muse as etc.
The phrase of the theme of the major holiday of Lightning at the time of the first
Sati.  I think I have the feeling that I'm making something like the foundation of what Final Fantasy will be like, so
I have the impression that sticky elements are coming into various places.
Well, I think it's quite Parker c. It
feels
like it's coming out quite a bit, and in the end it has to be connected to whether it's interesting or not.
Even as a point, I think it's a job to think hard as a goal point.
I'm trying to make something that will be memorable when
I hear it, so music is just one transformation element in the game, isn't it?
This is the only material for making one game.  I think that the image of "Osan"
has a lot to do
with FINAL FANTASY. Now, let us just say that FINAL FANTASY is the music of the work.
I mean, it's a place where we
have to express something different from our current generation, while still spicing it up, isn't it?
Sr music with Action Stalation So Wither-kun Bounce Tree
Unique  One of the fun things about making a breast ler is interviewing. I often
see the scenery, buildings, photos, and yes photos that I see when walking around the city,
but even if I say it as a reference, I actually go to that
scale.  It's surprisingly big that I felt it with my skin, like the feeling of air
, and I want to take care of it,
but Fukiji was good.
After all 8 hey
There are various locations within easy reach, and when I'm a little stuck in policy,
I go to those places and send it to the part of the year, or the seaside
, etc.
I went to a place where I was standing, and while walking in such a place,
I was worried about what to do now
.  I'm trying to make this kind of paste, so I used to take it home and pour it into the data at the site.
I thought about creating a world view that would be a new world called Cristalia, which is the new world of Lightning Return Suwa
. The
first was to create a small island, so I started
up.  However, as ideas gradually came in from there
, the
small islands gradually expanded
, and each island was divided into islands, and the feature was the first time in a day, and one
was peacefully in front of, for example, 4 to God.  Quiet people who live while praying Class 6
There is a religion to let them go. The
ruins of the Shinkoshinto are the
chaotic lines
.
It seems like a
small village in the place called Wildanes and
the remnants of the ruins that appeared in the previous work.
There are a lot of deserts and 8th place, and there are a lot of red silver in it. I
bought a tiger line and the reading is white
.  There is a parade or anxiety that I can't really enjoy.
Ah Fountain Day America
Diatia Las Vegas or something like that, but those four types are the specifics of this time.
I'm running like this,
so I'd like to get on and move to the town where it's stopped. Well, it's
better than me every time, isn't it
?  I think that I can pursue that gorgeous or unique world view that has the fantasy of Las Vegas
. From the Night 2 model
, the texture and
how to move the facial expressions are all reviewed underground for the time being.
Further upgrade of Lightning
up to usa is a big ice field picture book Patty Ma Almost ace animation
roc I'm going to take it with capture Go Adulin Nuu Ah Ah
I was
all at school
What is it?
The
part that you see and the part that you touch is not an effective way to open, but the boundary line becomes
ambiguous or
is fused. In the current game, you can see the high quality instructions and
naturally yourself.  You can control the operation of the character to move the character, or is it the dora
thing?
The
banquet is changed by your own investigation,
and it is evolving into the middle part, so even though you are a more
beautiful navigator, you can make more pop.  I think it's evolving to the extent that it can be
done.  Bringing the entire team toward one vision
I think that was one of our strengths.
I'm a person who is passionate about making products. It's useless if you don't do it
so seriously. It makes me think so much.
The world I want to express is that each staff member has a good idea of how to put t
gether what they have and make it as a group
Even so, riddim I'm going home so much
Well, this time it's the last work of Lightning,
so I'm sure everyone thinks that it's the degree of change that came from that Final Fantasy Starteen.  The contents have
changed from now on, and you
can enjoy that adventure here
ender ender ender action rpg nase to do
new
To be more
specific, it happens that the second place
called a game happens to
be
very cool, so I'm talking and playing on that big day, but at
that time, what kind of thing will be Final Fantasy 25 years later?  I
can't really imagine being called and losing, for example,
I'm sure I don't know if it's a liner hand child, or if it's a different expression
, if I can meet the next generation, I'll know Fanta.
I made a work with a stain on my back and
made it very much
tan